ucrania tiene un nuevo objetivo
restaurar el dominio ucraniano sobre la
península de crimea anexionada por rusia
en 2014 así lo manifestó el presidente
selenski en una cumbre para abordar este
tema en la que participaron
representantes de unos 60 estados y
organizaciones internacionales
para superar el terror para devolver las
garantías la seguridad a nuestra región
a europa al mundo entero es necesario
obtener la victoria en la lucha contra
la agresión rusa por lo tanto es
necesario liberar crimea de la ocupación
donde todo comenzó allí terminará esta
será la resucitación efectiva de la ley
y el orden de invierno
selenski también dijo que rusia había
convertido a crimea en una zona de
desastre ecológico y un trampolín
militar para la agresión y es que rusia
ha utilizado la península como
plataforma para disparar 750 misiles de
crucero contra objetivos ucranianos pero
ucrania cuenta con el apoyo de la
comunidad internacional
francia y la unión europea con una serie
de aliados y amigos de ucrania están
haciendo todo lo necesario para apoyar
su lucha porque es una lucha justa es
una lucha por su soberanía por su
integridad territorial y nuestra
determinación no ha cambiado y estamos
dispuestos a mantener este esfuerzo a
largo plazo
w
desde el 9 de agosto los ataques en
crimea se han intensificado el sábado la
sede de la flota del mar negro de rusia
en esta localidad fue atacada con un
drone se trata del segundo ataque contra
el estado mayor en crimea en menos de un
mes